welcome to the world of machine learning
as we embrace the Innovations of
tomorrow here are the top 10 projects
that will Skyrocket your skills in the
ever evolving landscape of machine
learning and artificial intelligence the
project number one is image recognition
with convolutional neural network or CNN
delve into the domain of image
recognition with a focus on
convolutional neural networks this
project serves as an introduction to the
intricacies of CNN architectures aing an
image classification and feature
extraction
offering a foundational understanding of
visual data processing tools needed to
work on this project includes Python
tensorflow and cars skills that you will
learn are image processing CNN
architecture tensorflow usage and much
more moving on to project number two we
have sentiment analysis with natural
language processing or NLP engage in the
analysis of sentiment using natural
language processing tools this project
aims to instill the skills necessary for
text pre-processing feature extraction
and sentiment analysis contributing to a
comprehensive understanding of emotional
context with textual data tools needed
to work on this project are Python nltk
and SEC the skills you will acquire
includes text pre-processing feature
extraction and sentiment analysis moving
on to project number three we have
reinforcement learning with open a gy
Master the principles of reinforcement
learning through the utilization of the
open AI gym environment this project
focuses on Q learning policy iteration
and and the Practical implementation of
reinforcement learning algorithms
facilitating a deeper comprehension of
decision- making systems tools needed to
work on this projects include python
open a skills you will acquire includes
Q learning deep Q networks and policy
iteration moving on to project number
four we have generative adversarial
networks or Gans for image generation
explore the creative possibilities of
generative adversarial networks in
crafting synthetic images this Advanced
project dels into the architect C of G
offering insight into image generation
and adversarial Network Frameworks tools
needed to work on this project includes
Python tlow and caras skills that you
will acquire include G and architecture
image generation and adversarial
networks moving on to project number
five we have time series forecasting
with long short-term memory or lstm
networks enhance predictive capabilities
through the study of long short-term
memory networks this project addresses
time series data handling lstm
architectures and sequence prediction
enabling adeptness in forecasting
sequential data tools needed includes
Python kasas and palas the skills you
will acquire includes time series data
handling lscm architecture sequence
prediction moving on to project number
six we have object detection using YOLO
you only look once examine realtime
object detection techniques with you
only look once model this intermediate
level project focuses on object
recognition YOLO architecture and
computer vision culminating in the app
to detect and categorize objects swiftly
tools needed includes python open CV and
darket skills you will learn includes
object detection YOLO architecture and
computer vision moving on to the next
project we have Transformer models for
language translation embark on a
linguistic Journey exploring Transformer
models for language translation dive
into the mechanics of attention
mechanisms enabling a comprehensive
understanding of language translation
and transformative capabilities of those
models tools needed includes python
hugging face Transformers the skills you
will acquire includes transform
architectures attention mechanisms and
language translation moving on to
project number eight we have Federated
learning for privacy preserving machine
learning explore the Paradigm of privacy
preserving machine learning with a focus
on Federated learning this Advanced
project emphasizes secure Collaborative
Learning techniques facilitating the
enhancement of models while ensuring
data privacy tools needed to work on
this project project are Python
tensorflow and pis skills that you will
acquire includes Federated learning
secure and privacy preserving ml moving
on to project number nine we have
reinforcement learning for realtime
strategy Gams develop strategic decision
making skills through reinforcement
learning with a realtime strategy games
this project focuses on empowering AI
agents with strategic Pros thereby
owning decision making capabilities in
game environments the tools needed
includes Python and PC2 moving on to the
skills you will learn out of this
project includes strategic decision
making RL in game environments moving on
to the last project for the video we
have explainable ai for model
interpretability unveil the Integra of
model interpretability through
explainable AI techniques the skills you
will acquire include Model
interpretability H Techni so That's all
folks for this top 10 machine learning
project ideas
2024 make sure to check out our other
amazing videos on machine learning and
let us know your feedback like in the
comments thank you so much for being
here we'll see you next time until then
keep learning and stay tuned to simp
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upscaling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here